I figure since we are past Election Day
now on the classic interview this Friday
today we will go back to just a good
old-fashioned right-wing not interview
and this is Stacey Campfield the
Tennessee State Senator this was a
conversation we had the incredibly
anti-gay Stacey Campfield kicked out of
a restaurant in Tennessee for being
anti-gay I know that this is a favorite
of many in our audience I know lots of
our new viewers and listeners have never
heard this so we're gonna play it for
you let's revisit my interview with
Stacey Campfield back from January of
2012 Tennessee State Senator Stacey
Campfield Republican from Knoxville is
back on the show he made some news last
week when he did an interview with
Sirius XM's Michael Angelo senior really
uh senator you made a number of claims
during that interview including that it
was virtually impossible to contract
aids through heterosexual sex uh you
also said that homosexuality is is very
uh is is dangerous tell me what exactly
is harmful about homosexuality that
maybe is a good place to start
sure we'll be active homosexuality I
mean if you're talking about anal sex is
very very mature so if this is too
graphic for some people but it is very
risky behavior and have a very high rate
of catching disease from it uh vaginal
intercourse between a man the woman your
odds are actually and I've got links on
my blog at WWF star dot blog spot.com I
have uh links to say that the odds of
someone actually catching aid from uh
vaginal intercourse for just an average
person not a high risk person an average
person about 1 in 5 million now
obviously if you're having sex with
ninety drug user homosexual bisexuals uh
hemophiliacs people who are from Africa
uh the continent of Africa are not
African per se but you know people
actually from their garage hours ago up
but uh expert in America your odds of
catching it through heterosexual contact
contact with non high-risk people about
one in five million yet you know it's
interesting because you
saying something which is very common
with a lot of uh I guess anti-gay
individuals which is when you ask them
what's bad about homosexuality they they
obsess about two men having sex uh and
it's incredible to me because
homosexuality is something that exists
in you know as I'm sure you know
thousands of of animal species across
you know tens of millions of years if
you believe the earth has been around
that long uh why does the focus about
homosexuality in a moral sense become
about two men having sex how can we take
that and say homosexuality is is immoral
or harmful I don't understand that why
is the fixation on on on anal sex
well obviously like I said because it
first of all if it's not healthy
lifestyle it's very dangerous the
average homosexual prevail variety of
reason has about a lifespan about twenty
four years shorter than the average
person
uh yeah well you got nurse alone I got
that from call Paul Cameron who's been
widely discredited that statistic has
been widely discredited and I mean if
you had if you got it from somewhere
other than Paul Cameron let me know but
I looked into it and that's actually
there's uh participates for uh insurance
companies who do that sort of thing and
this will now is this correct trying to
spare they always say well what about
older men monogamous relationships yeah
I hate to say it but most homosexual
relationship I should say most many
homosexual relationships are not
monogamous they're much more horrific I
guess it's the word and we're there uh
with what they do in their life in the
paranoia
we're statistics on it when actually if
you look at those we get a lot of this
information you can pull this
information up look at insurance
statistics if you are a homosexual man
your insurance rates go through the roof
and the reason is because you have so
much longer shorter life span which
insurance rates health insurance life
insurance there's the call the others
and another new 'ti rates but uh there
and by the way you mentioned some other
things about uh it has been it's been
animal kingdom forever and ever
yeah you know I I tend to disagree with
that I've never seen you know and again
I'm if you use graphic language sir but
I've never seen or known of an animal
sodomizing another animal so let me see
if I understand uh what you're saying is
that the the the idea that homosexuality
has existed in a percentage of thousands
of species over the history of time to
you it doesn't strike you is true
because you've never seen two animals
having anal sex and do I understand that
correctly sir you know I know I just I
haven't seen that I can't get a test for
it after I've never seen it you've never
seen two animals having sex therefore
there is not homosexuality in the animal
kingdom but don't want to misstate you
know not their thing I know animals they
sort of like if they fake it I guess
whatever to show dominance over one
another but I've never actually seen one
animal sodomized another animal now so
in other words the the homosexual
activity you observed in animals seems
to be almost like an S&M dominance type
of thing but is not evidence to you of
actual homosexuality in any other
species other than humans is that right
I you know I can't speak for what an
animal's thinking in their head or in
their heart now well you just said you
don't agree as a dominance thing that's
that's that implies you know the intent
doesn't it they how would you know its
dominance well that's what most people
have said there's more of a show of
dominance when they they do that they're
showing dominance over another animal
which who's most people well if you want
to get online I guess you look that up
so you've called anti-gay bullying a
lark uh what did you mean by that we
already have it homosexuals are covered
by anti-bullying laws or a bull
blowing laws already say that we need
new bullying laws and you know we need
to have special groups come in to talk
to children about homosexuality because
of bullying is not really true so your
your concern is is what that somebody
would come into schools and tell
children what that homosexuality exists
that it's okay that it what's your
concern in the few know what's the
nitty-gritty of the concern I just don't
think that's the mission we need to be
talking about the principles I don't
believe that's something we need to be
taught by our schools our schools in
Tennessee we're ranked about 46th in the
nation and a nation that is slipping
from we used to be at the top of the of
the world right really now we're
slipping down you know we're not
studying we're not even passing math
science a lot of our major things we're
having problems getting through that yet
we decide we or some people would really
like for teachers to go out there and
start saying let's talk to you about the
complex life of homosexuals or sexuality
Willie was a Mason even though that I
even though there may not be teachers
are not psychologists they're not
psychiatrists they are not I don't think
they're someone who knows when every
child in the classroom may be prepared
to hear about these issues I just don't
think that's appropriate for children
young children so should they also not
talk about heterosexual marriages maybe
that's not something children are
prepared to hear about if they are not
psychologists who are they to say well
we've determined they can hear about
heterosexual marriages but not
homosexual marriages it seems very
arbitrary senator well actually we don't
teach that actually man my bill would
take their like if my bill talks about
his natural reproduction what's your
reaction to to our home state of
Massachusetts here which was the first
to legalize gay marriage and and has
very strong anti bullying and other
anti-discrimination legislation related
to homosexuality we're doing incredibly
well education wise what's going on I
don't think the two are connected
properly down I think you know you may
be doing great with education there may
be other factors there that hate may be
fantasy wants to model but is it
homosexuality that's something we have
to it education on homosexuality is that
somehow think your
educational system better I'm seeing a
proof of that like I said we've had some
great legislation terribly I don't think
anybody like should be bullied no matter
what what lifestyle they have a kids get
boys any kids get boys small kids get
bullied and when you say lifestyle you
know that somebody just chooses to be
homosexual if you when you say lifestyle
you you mean someone chooses to live a
homosexual lifestyle is that right use
me when you say lifestyle am i right to
hear that you're saying somebody who is
homosexual has chosen that lifestyle
well I mean I don't have the activity I
think is a choice we are human beings so
we have choice over what we do with
ourselves so they someone chooses to
have sex or yeah I'd say that that's
pretty much about right okay hey last
thing I know you have to go because you
have another interview coming up is it
true yesterday you were kicked out of
the bistro at the Bijou on Gay Street by
owner Martha Boggs because she didn't
like your anti-gay stances is that true
well yeah it is true she asked me to
leave that's unfortunate that some
people you know we can't sit down and
talk about issues that it's always funny
I always say liberals are the most
open-minded people the different points
of view until someone actually has a
different point of view and then they
sort of freak out don't know how to
handle people with different points of
view so in a sense people you might say
you might have you were unfairly
discriminated against would you say that
what some people have said that you know
the civil rights my civil rights were
violated if I were to base it on my
religious beliefs based based uh my
views on my religious beliefs that I
would I would be covered by the 1964
Civil Rights Act I haven't really said
that right but so I guess I guess
forgetting aside your head on the second
spill what I guess you're getting a
little bit of a sense for how homosexual
people feel when they're discriminated
against are maybe senator well I you
know I'll be honest with you I would not
frequent a place that said we're not
going to serve homosexuals at a
restaurant I'll go there okay no I would
not if someone said hey I'm not gonna
serve homosexuals I don't think we
should be discriminating based on that I
don't think that the valid reason you
know senator that I think that's the
best thing we that's the one thing we've
we agree on the most from this interview
Tennessee State Senator Stacey Campfield
Republican from Knoxville
I will let you go I know you have that
other interview going thank you so much
for joining us no prob take care